eso
[Música]
retrocedamos en el tiempo por unos
segundos
en enero del 2020 hace 11 meses yo les
estaba diciendo que estamos viviendo una
crisis de aprendizajes que a pesar de
que en los últimos 40 años la matrícula
en primaria y secundaria ha crecido más
chicos están en el aula estamos
enfrentando una crisis de aprendizajes y
eso porque a pesar de estar en el aula
muchos chicos no están obteniendo las
habilidades fundamentales pero como
sabemos que eso está pasando si vemos
nosotros los los indicadores de los
objetivos de desarrollo y desarrollo
sostenible encontramos que los países
hacen seguimiento en un conjunto grande
de indicadores de educación de
asistencia repitencia tecnología
infraestructura etcétera y todos los
indicadores son muy útiles para quienes
diseñan políticas y para los expertos
que analizan los sistemas educativos
pero decenas de indicadores no
necesariamente es hacer fácil que
cualquier persona como ustedes creo que
no son necesariamente expertos en
educación sepa lo que está pasando con
aprendizaje los chicos por eso creamos
un indicador que fuera fácil de entender
para cualquier persona y justamente hace
un año lanzamos en el banco mundial un
indicador que llamamos pobres
aprendizajes este indicador es el
porcentaje de los niños de 10 años que
no pueden leer y entender un texto
simple
si lo piensan bien y piensen ustedes en
sus hijos en los chicos que están en la
casa en este momento ese indicador
debería ser cero todos los chicos a los
diez años deberían poder leer y entender
un texto ese indicador debería ser cero
como lo es el hambre como en la pobreza
extrema
ahora es indicador a mí me gusta mucho
porque es un indicador sencillo
cualquiera lo puede entender pero muchas
personas me preguntaron antes porque la
lectura si es que hay tantos otros
objetivos importantes en educación
porque solamente nos interesa la lectura
y les digo porque primero porque leer y
entender es un derecho humano es un
derecho de todos los niños y es por eso
que nos importa tanto solamente por eso
pero además la lectura es necesaria para
cualquier otro objetivo de educación al
que nos importe si un chico puede leer y
comprender bien lo que lee le va a ir
mejor en matemáticas va a entender mejor
ciencias va a entender mejor historia va
a poder adquirir más habilidades
socioemocionales que nos interesan tanto
y en general lo que nosotros vemos que
los sistemas educativos que preparan a
sus hijos bien para poder leer y
entender son sistemas educativos que nos
preparan bien en todas las otras
habilidades para la vida que los que nos
que nos interesa entonces la pregunta es
cómo estábamos en este indicador de
pobreza de aprendizajes en enero del
y la cifra que teníamos para esa fecha
era de 53 por ciento es decir más de la
mitad de los niños no podían leer y
entender un texto en los países de
ingreso medio e ingreso bajo
que esto esté pasando eso no es un
problema
eso es una crisis es una crisis
gravísima
ahora movamos el vídeo a junio del 2020
y que está pasando en ese momento en
junio de 2020
en ese momento teníamos 1600 millones de
chicos que
estaban fuera de las aulas debido a la
pandemia en casi todos los países del
mundo las aulas estaban cerradas y
teníamos un séptimo de la humanidad que
debía estar en el colegio
y que estaba en sus casas o en sus
comunidades y que además de que las
escuelas estaban cerradas como
consecuencia de estas medidas contra la
pandemia estaba muy viendo y todavía
estamos en unos casos viviendo la crisis
económica más grande de los últimos 100
años y porque una crisis económica nos
importa en educación porque las familias
entonces tienen menos recursos para
poder invertir en educación y porque los
los gobiernos tienen menos recursos para
invertir en él para invertir en la
educación esto es un shock doble sin
precedentes nunca habíamos vivido un
cierre de escuelas prolongados como este
combinado con una recesión tan grave
como está ahora como consecuencia de
esos prolongados cierre de escuelas y a
pesar de los esfuerzos de muchos
gobiernos por implementar la estrategia
de aprendizaje remoto encontramos que
hay pérdidas de aprendizaje muy graves
entre entre los chicos por ese
desenganche que ha habido del sistema
escolar
ese indicador que yo les decía que en
enero era el 53% lo que nosotros estamos
simulando es que ahora puede estar
llegando a 63 por ciento ese es un
número altísimo y eso es eso es un
problema extremadamente grave pero no
solamente es la pérdida de aprendizaje
que tenemos como impactos en el sistema
educativo además de eso encontramos un
problema grave de deserción calculamos
que unos 10 millones de chicos no van a
regresar a las las escuelas luego de
esta crisis además sabemos que hay
problemas graves de salud mental entre
los chicos entre los profesores
encontramos que como consecuencia de
este de este desenganche de las menores
del menor número de años de escolaridad
que los chicos van a tener que esta
generación puede estar perdiendo muchos
ingresos futuros en calculamos que van a
estar perdiendo 10 trillones de ingresos
futuros que corresponde a un 10 por
ciento del pd y más o menos lo gracias
una cifra muy grande de ingresos futuros
que esta generación va a para ver y
además tenemos un problema grave de
desigualdad y déjeme explicarle
explayarme un poquito más en este tema
es de desigualdad como consecuencia la
crisis los países no se incluso de
brazos los países todos los países ricos
y pobres y han invertido en estrategias
de desarrollo de remoto en primer lugar
en el lugar han intentado invertir en
internet en tratar de llegar en línea a
los chicos pero obviamente no lo pueden
llevar en línea a todos los chicos
porque no todos los chicos tienen
conectividad a su casa en los países más
pobres de áfrica subshariana por ejemplo
solamente el 10 por ciento de chicos
tienen conexiones en su en su casa en
américa latina' ese número está entre el
50 y 60 por ciento entonces según los
todos los países han tenido que regresar
a la televisión a la radio a repartir
material impreso lograrlo para los
profesores se han conectado con los
chicos a través de whatsapp y de
teléfonos inteligentes en todo entonces
han sido en todos los casos estrategias
multiplataformas
pero cuando comparamos lo que ha pasado
las distintas regiones vemos que esas
estrategias de aprendizaje remoto han
tenido distintos grados de efectividad y
de penetración en áfrica por ejemplo
encontramos que la mitad de los chicos
no han tenido acceso a nada a ningún
tipo de aprendizaje remoto en el caso de
américa latina encontramos que el 93 por
ciento de los chicos han tenido acceso
acceso a algún tipo de aprendizaje
remoto y eso no está mal no sólo
hicieron bueno 93 por ciento es número
bastante alto
lamentablemente hay diferencias muy
grandes en las experiencias que los
chicos han tenido al interior de américa
latina- en algunos casos encontramos
chicos que en sus hogares han estado en
un lugar apropiado para poder trabajar
tienen conexión a internet y se han
conectado con sus con sus profesores y
con sus compañeros tienen material de
lectura en casa en cambio en el otro
extremo encontramos chicos que con lech
o solamente pueden acceder a un programa
de radio en una zona rural o que tienen
que cambiar un par de horas para poder
lograr señal de internet en el teléfono
inteligente de sus padres entonces
tenemos experiencias muy distintas entre
chicos ricos y entre chicos entre los
chicos más pobres esto lo hemos podido
cuantificar en algunos en algunos casos
y le muestro la experiencia de colombia
en los cual en el cual en el quintil más
pobre de ingresos calculamos que va a
haber una pérdida de aprendizajes del
95%
en el quintil más rico de ingresos
encontramos una pérdida bastante grande
también no de más del 50 por ciento
entonces finalmente encontramos que hay
un impacto muy fuerte sobre sobre los
aprendizajes y al mismo tiempo un
impacto muy desigual que es algo que nos
tiene que preocupar muchísimo tenemos
entonces si ya decíamos les decía yo que
en enero al 2020 estaban viviendo una
crisis tenemos una crisis ahora otra
crisis pero déjenme cerrar en estos
últimos minutos hablando de dos
lecciones importantes que nos puede dar
esta pandemia y si aprendemos de
selecciones y trabajamos obras
elecciones podemos lograr un sistema
educativo más eficaz y más equitativo
una primera lección es que los sistemas
educativos tienen que ser más
resilientes siempre pueden haber
interrupciones en la vida escolar puede
haber un huracán en haití un monzón en
la india o un terremoto en perú en el
paco en pakistán y los países tienen que
estar preparados pero estar preparados
implica asegurar que haya una
continuidad en el proceso educativo
entre la escuela y el hogar y esa
continuidad requiere por un lado una
escuela que tenga las condiciones
correctas y funcione bien pero por otro
lado como se ha mostrado esta pandemia
requiere que en el hogar tengamos las
condiciones correctas para poder
aprender y tener las condiciones
correctas en el hogar implica muchas
cosas pero déjenme hablarles de dos
ingredientes primero debe hablar de los
padres familias yo creo que esta
pandemia nos ha mostrado la fundamental
importancia de los padres en el proceso
educativo de los estudiantes los padres
los quieran no son protagonistas del
futuro de sus hijos
y no es fácil es un esfuerzo heroico que
hay que hacer en todo momento no esas
pequeñas acciones en el día a día en el
cual los padres enseñan con el ejemplo
enseñan sobre perseverancia sobre
empatía enseñan a hacer que el respeto a
los demás y también son muchas acciones
en el día a día para crear un ambiente
propicio para que los chicos puedan
puedan aprender en el hogar algunos
padres han internalizado bien ese
proceso pero no todos y segundo tenemos
que entender que hay diferencias en las
condiciones materiales de los ovarios
como le decía en algunos en algunos
casos hay un chico que tiene internet en
su casa que tiene libros tiene un
espacio de trabajar y en el otro extremo
chicos no tienen nada de eso pero la
política pública puede incidir en eso la
política pública puede mejorar también
las condiciones en el hogar y déjeme
darle tres ejemplos en primer lugar un
programa que se llama wire at home no
leyendo en casa del banco mundial que
tiene como objetivo llegar masivamente
con material de lectura a todos los
hogares particularmente los hogares más
más pobres
y además llegando además de ese material
lectura con guías para los padres para
que puedan apoyar en el proceso a los
chicos y guías que no son solamente para
padres que saben leer bien sino también
para padres que pueden tener
dificultades en el proceso de lectura
segundo muchos programas que existen de
consejería de información y de apoyo a
los padres para que puedan ser un
soporte en el proceso educativo de los
de de los chicos en tercer lugar en el
perú por ejemplo se están implementando
programas de reparto de un millón de
tablets a los chicos y de hogares con
más necesidades que es un programa muy
difícil de implementar pero es un
programa que va en la dirección correcta
en ese sentido con la política pública
podemos apoyar que haya una continuidad
de aprendizaje y que mejoren las
condiciones en el hogar
y la segunda lección que les quería
mencionar es que la escuela del futuro
del futuro cercano es una escuela en el
cual se logre un balance entre la
tecnología y el factor humano en primer
lugar sobre tecnología tenemos que
cerrar la brecha digital hemos hablado
durante 20 años que existe una brecha
digital esa brecha digital no se había
cerrado y hoy estamos pagando las
consecuencias de eso y tenemos que
avanzar mucho más rápida y eso no
implica es solamente la conectividad
sino implica asegurarnos que los chicos
tengan acceso a un dispositivo que haya
el software adecuado y que los los
maestros tengan la capacitación para
utilizar correctamente las tecnologías
tecnologías pero por otro lado está el
factor humano y lo que esta pandemia nos
ha demostrado es que la educación es un
fenómeno social que la magia del
aprendizaje se da en esa interacción
entre el maestro y el estudiante y
muchísimo se puede hacer con la
tecnología pero la tecnología para
apoyar el trabajo de los maestros el
chico finalmente puede leer en wikipedia
acerca del cambio climático puede leer
en un libro pero finalmente es el
maestro
el que lo guía el que lo reiteró que lo
ayuda a ser creativo el que le enseña a
trabajar en equipo el que lo apoya si es
que está desmotivado el que le enseña a
cuestionar el que les haya enseñado
opinar y los buenos maestros nos marcan
para siempre
los buenos maestros no son solamente una
fuente de conocimiento sino son una guía
para desarrollar las habilidades para la
vida pero y está mucho más difícil de
hacer lo que solamente será una fuente
de conocimientos ustedes estoy seguro
que recuerdan con nombre y apellido
aquel maestro que dijo algo o hizo algo
que los hizo pensar de una manera
distinta que les cambió la vida décadas
después se van a acordar de sedes de esa
persona eso es eso muestra la
importancia del maestro en la vida de
todas las personas ahora muchos maestros
son efectivamente si son excelentes pero
no pueden ser muchos
tiene que ser todos los maestros y como
logramos que todos los maestros sean
excelentes ser excelente requiere
práctica requiere mucha práctica
requiere mucho esfuerzo tú no te subes
un avión con un piloto que ha aprendido
al manejar la nave en un libro o en un
aula tu te subes un avión confiado con
un piloto que tiene 10.000 horas es
bueno lo mismo sucede con los maestros
el buen maestro es aquel que practica
constantemente aquel que recibe consejo
de sus padres no hacen a aquel que se
inspira del profesor más experimentado
permanentemente por eso necesitamos
apoyar en invertir con entrenamiento
práctico a los 60 millones de maestros
que hoy día están en las aulas frente a
nuestros chicos porque tenemos que
asegurar que su interacción con los
estudiantes sea cada vez mejor pero
además tenemos que invertirlo maestro
del futuro y como sabemos si vamos en
buen camino
cuando hablamos de invertir en los
maestros que vienen y que van a estar en
el futuro nuestras aulas hay ese que yo
quiero que recuerden una cosa que lo que
predice
cuando un sistema educativo es exitoso
no lo que predice eso es la valoración
social de la carrera del maestro en un
país la carrera el maestro debe ser
exigente debe ser retadora pero debe ser
un orgullo para toda la familia que su
hijo su hija escoja ser docente cuando
eso pase es que nos estaremos dando
cuenta que tenemos un sistema educativo
de buena calidad yo creo que esta
pandemia nos ha demostrado varias cosas
nos ha demostrado que los padres son
protagonistas del futuro sus hijos nos
ha demostrado que necesitamos cerrar la
brecha digital nos ha demostrado que los
maestros son fundamentales que la
siguiente generación esté en sus manos
que tenemos que invertir los maestros de
hoy y lo maestro del futuro y también
nos ha mostrado a esta pandemia que todo
esto es urgente
y les les digo porque es urgente y se lo
quiero decir más bien con una anécdota
cuando you tube el honor de ser el
ministro de educación en el perú
implementamos un programa que se llamaba
jornada escolar completa que se llama
jornada escolar completa y es un
programa en el cual las escuelas
secundarias recibían más infraestructura
y más equipamiento los maestros tenían
más capacitación y los chicos estaban
más horas en el aula y yo visité
muchísimas de estas escuelas y siempre
les preguntaba a los chicos qué les
parecía que le parecía que esta
experiencia estar más tiempo con sus
profesores y con sus compañeros y la
respuesta siempre era entusiasta mente
positiva pero visitando una escuela en
chulucanas en piura en el norte del perú
un chico que estaba en quinto de
secundaria me dijo si esto está muy bien
pero eso está muy bien para los chicos
de primero y de segundo y secundaria
nuestro instinto ya me estoy yendo para
mí llegaron muy tarde
y yo no tenía respuesta para ese chico
y yo creo que seguimos llegando tarde
seguimos llegando tarde en muchos países
en indonesia en marruecos en perú
seguimos llegando tarde y tenemos que
avanzar más rápido y yo no quisiera
volver a tener esa conversación ni
quisiera que ningún otro ministro de
educación tenga esa conversación tenemos
que a va a ser más rápido no podemos
volver a llegar tarde muchas gracias